Hey guys, Mark here. In this video, I'm
going to be explaining how the entire
Meta Ads algorithm actually works. A lot
of people think that running ads on
Facebook is just all random or that if
your creative is good enough, then
everything else will just magically fall
into place. Well, running profitable ads
on Facebook is both an art and a
science. The art is the creative, but
the science is exactly what I'm going to
be explaining in this video, how the
algorithm actually works. And more
specifically than a science, it's
actually an equation. And this is the
one equation that is actually going to
determine how profitable your ads are
going to be. Now, before I break down
this equation, I need to explain to you
the four-step process that Facebook uses
to actually show your ads, the one
update that broke everybody's ad
account, and at the end of this video,
I'm going to put in a little something
special to explain what this actually
all means and how the game really works.
All right, so before we get too
technical, this is what you have to
understand. Facebook basically goes
through a four-step process to determine
which ad is going to show for any
particular user. Every time somebody
opens up their phone on Instagram and
they scroll and see an ad behind the
means there's literally a 200
millisecond window where Facebook is
doing all these incredible calculations
and machine learning decisions to
ultimately decide to put your ad in
front of the user or somebody else's.
So, in that one 200 millisecond period,
there is literally tens of millions of
ads that are competing for that one
impression. And these are the four steps
right here. First, you have retrieval.
Second is light ranking. Third is heavy
ranking. And the final piece is the
auction. So, let me break this down for
you. So, first up is retrieval.
Retrieval is the most data-intensive
portion of this entire process because
as I said, there's tens of millions of
ads, tens of millions that are competing
for one individual spot. The process of
retrieval is essentially Facebook going
through and ultimately deciding, is the
ad right now even remotely relevant to
this user? Basically, like is it even in
the right ballpark? Now, this is also
the portion of the process where
Facebook actually analyzes all the
aspects of your creative to determine
how to narrow down the audience. So, you
may have heard this before, but this
whole concept of your creative is your
targeting. This is where Facebook is
analyzing everything about your creative
to determine who to show it to. This
includes, but is not limited to, your
hook, your format, the demographic of
the users that are actually on your ad.
So, for example, if you're running an ad
that is featuring a woman that is 55
years old, Facebook takes note of that
and it's going to use that to power the
targeting to skew much more towards
women and skew much more towards older
women specifically. Of course, all taken
into context with what the creative is
actually saying. It's also looking at
your copy, it's looking at your script.
If you're running video ads, it's
looking at your thumbnail. It's even
going and looking at your landing page
to determine generally who is this ad
trying to target. This is a
non-exhaustive list. I'm really
simplifying this. Behind the scenes,
it's a pretty substantial, literally an
algorithm in order to determine which
variable is going to correlate to which
piece of targeting. And this is probably
a good time to mention the Andromeda
update. Andromeda what is was an update
to the sorting process of the retrieval
steps specifically. Mostly just because
there was a massive influx of AI
creative that was absolutely flooding
Facebook to the point where their old
model of sifting through all these
creatives was not becoming very
effective. This is not the only reason
for the Andromeda update, but I believe
this is one of the biggest ones simply
due to the fact that AI has massively
increased creative production for all
advertisers. And now that's why Facebook
is mostly looking at creative to
determine targeting, not what you have
going on within your ad sets. That's why
you've probably seen a decline in
audiences that are actually able to
sustain high budgets profitably. Like I
rarely use audiences like interest, and
if I do, they're pretty capped in terms
of budget or, you know, lookalikes or
even custom audiences. Like I don't set
any real [__] targeting when it comes
to my retargeting. I don't put any
custom audiences in there. I literally
just still run completely broad. And
most high-skill advertisers that I speak
to, they're doing something relatively
similar. Maybe one exclusion of
purchasers, but like other than that,
very, very broad. So, if that was kind
of the old way of doing targeting on
Facebook, the new way is to do a lot of
broad targeting. It's to do a lot of
Advantage Plus campaigns, and it's
usually within reason, within reason.
Giving Facebook control. Like the reason
that I say it's within reason is because
if you give Facebook all the control,
the algorithm is good, don't get me
wrong, but holy [__] the amount of
suggestions that Facebook gives you that
are horrible pieces of advice that are
just going to drain your [__] bank
account is obscene. And it's always been
this way, too. They're still a company
at the end of the day, and you are a
customer. You are paying Facebook, so
they still want to get your money. I'll
save that for later in the video. Now,
the second step is going to be light
ranking. This step barely deserves a
description. It's basically taking the
now millions of ads instead of tens of
millions, and reducing it down to
thousands. There's really not a a whole
lot more to say about the light ranking
process. Now, the heavy ranking is the
next step, which, you guessed it, if
it's going from thousands of ads, you're
now trying to get to a couple hundred.
Now, at this point, this is like your
real, legitimate competitors. Like this
is the stage where competitors are
actually something that you should take
into consideration, because you don't
have tens of millions of competitors.
You just don't. You probably only have a
handful, at least in the eyes of
Facebook, you only have a handful.
There's only 10 million advertisers
total on Facebook, which may seem like a
massive number, but also think about we
are in e-commerce specifically, at least
I'm in e-commerce specifically, which
immediately narrows it pretty
substantially. Now, the really important
piece about the heavy ranking step is
that this is where that equation
actually comes into play. So, I want to
take a second to talk about that,
because I remember Facebook released
this. They have since withdrawn it, but
they released this documentation to
explain how they actually assign a
specific value for every single ad when
they are fighting for an impression. And
the one that has a higher value,
obviously, is going to win the
impression and the one with the lower
value is going to lose the impression
and get served a lower quality
impression. All right, so this is the
equation I was talking about. This is
actually directly from Facebook.
Somebody swiped it and it is still on
their website, but it's not on Facebook.
But this is how it's actually working
underneath the hood, all right? So the
total value, this is what you want to
aim on maximizing, is equal to this
piece first of maximizing advertiser
value plus maximizing consumer value and
consumer experience. So the piece to
maximize your advertise value, number
one is going to be your bid, which we'll
get to in a second, times your estimated
action rate. Since 99% of us and 99% of
people watching this video are running
conversion campaigns, that essentially
means what is the estimated action rate
to get a conversion. And if you look
down here, you can see they actually
break it down specifically for a
conversion optimized ad, which is the
estimated click-through rate times the
estimated click-to-conversion rate. So
the way to get gamify this, of course,
is you want to have really high CTR.
Historically, Facebook just loves ads
that have really high CTR, and the
reason why is because that is the the
most pure indication of how relevant
that one particular ad is to the user.
So Facebook is going to reward you
typically over time and as you spend
more with lower cost to advertise, lower
CPMs, and ideally higher quality
traffic, too. So this is kind of like
the first piece of that. The second
piece is going to be you want to have a
high, they call it like
click-to-conversion. It's basically just
your conversion rate, which is out of
all the clicks that you had, how many
actually purchased. And again, if you're
running a e-commerce business, this is
going to be like a legitimate purchase
because that's typically what you're
optimizing for. But if you're in, you
know, the info industry, for example,
you're optimizing for calls, what is the
ratio between clicks to calls that
you're getting or clicks to applications
or insert your conversion here, it
doesn't really matter. Facebook views a
lot of this largely the same, at least
in the context of this equation. So the
way I like to think about this is the
estimated click-through rate, I think
it's actually more than the
click-through rate. I think it's a
culmination of all your soft metrics.
So, that is your CTR, but that's also
your CPC, your CPMs, your hook rate,
your hold rate, cost per 3-second video
view, like all these metrics that are
associated with getting somebody engaged
and getting them to click. And then the
second half of this is how good are you
at monetizing that click, taking that
click through your funnel, and turning
somebody who's a prospect into a buyer.
Pretty straightforward. And this last
piece is basically Facebook trying to
save their own ass from advertisers that
are incredibly aggressive and cause a
terrible user experience for the users.
Because if this piece just did not exist
and we didn't care about the user
experience whatsoever, advertisers would
just flood the platform and completely
just destroy Facebook as a platform
because you just have [__] loads of
scammers, not like there isn't scammers
on Facebook anyways, but there would be
way more. Like it would be like 50/50
instead of 80/20, which is roughly what
it is right now. So, this is Facebook
saying, "Hey, I want you to have the
most relevant ads to the user, which is
CTR, all the soft metrics, and I want
you to actually get conversions for all
the clicks that you're getting, which is
the conversion rate, and I don't want
you to piss off all of our [__] users
in the process." And that's the last
piece. All right, so we took it from
thousands of ads and now we're down to a
few hundred. In fact, sometimes it could
be even less than a few hundred. But now
we have the final step in the process,
which is going to be the auction. And
the auction is exactly what it sounds
like. It's all the advertisers that are
left competing for that one impression
and basically who can have the highest
bid, of course with all the context of
that equation that I said previously,
that's going to be the one that wins the
impression. So, majority of people
watching this video right now are
probably running what's called, you
know, lowest cost bidding or also known
as like auto bidding, which Facebook is
just doing all the bidding for you,
trying to get you conversions for the
lowest cost possible. This is, like I
said, auto bidding. You can also do
manual bidding, which can come in a few
different ways. Manual bidding, you can
do something called cost caps, which is
where you set a cap on the maximum
amount that you're willing to pay to
acquire a customer. You can also do bid
caps, which is similar, except it's the
maximum amount that you want to bid to
acquire a customer. And there's some
other stuff that Facebook is always
releasing as well to help you optimize,
you know, maximum value, target ROAS,
stuff like that. But I'll tell you this,
there's a lot of people that are really
obsessing about cost caps or bid caps or
whatever the hot, you know, manual
bidding method is at the time. I can
tell you for a fact, I have seen ad
accounts, I have ran ad accounts that
are spending multiple five figures per
day. I have seen one spending six
figures per day, all on lowest cost, and
they're good ad accounts. They are
profitable. Other people literally only
run bid caps. You can see both sides of
the spectrum, but the point is you
should choose what is actually going to
solve the constraint in your business
for you. Because I talk to people all
the time, they're like, "All right, in
order to get from like 1K a day to 10K
per day, I just got like media buy my
way there." And like there's a little
bit you can do, don't get me wrong. I'm
not the guy that's saying like media
buying is dead. I'm defending media
buying. At the same time, you have to
think like an entrepreneur, not like a
media buyer. And just to show this
entire process visually, all right, this
is how Facebook actually picks ads in
under 200 milliseconds. So this is the
first step, tens of millions of ads
competing for one impression. After
that, we go through the light ranking,
right? Now you can see there's
substantially less, say like roughly
5,000. Next step, there's just a few
hundred. Now we're going to go into
heavy ranking, which is boom, now we're
on the final step, which is actually
competing who's going to have the
highest bid. There's very few
advertisers left at this step, until
finally your ad is actually served. You
have the highest bid, you win the
impression. So again, retrieval, light
ranking, heavy ranking, and the auction
as the final step there. Okay, so now
you know how this filtering process
works, how does that actually affect
your ability to create winning ads
consistently and more importantly
predictably churn out winners into your
ad account. So there's a few other
things that aren't part of that
four-step ranking process that are still
really important to understand so that
you can have the most profitable ads as
possible. All right, first I want to
talk for a second about the learning
phase, okay? So, the learning phase,
according to Facebook themselves, is
basically a phase that your ads go
through, your ad sets go through, your
campaigns go through, but especially at
the ad level to acquire conversions so
that it can learn about your customer
and then you kind of exit the learning
phase and go into like mature phase
where you're getting more predictable
consistent results. Here's my beef with
this whole [__] term. Like that's the
theory. Let me tell you the [__]
reality. Your ads are always learning.
They never stop learning. There's not a
learning phase and then they get out of
learning phase and they're just going to
be good forever. Everything dies at some
point. It's just the circle of ads. So,
if you are obsessing over the learning
phase, just stop. Of course, the ads
initially are going to be a little bit
more volatile, a little bit more bumpy,
and sometimes you see improvements over
time with more consistency, but
sometimes you don't. Sometimes the
solution is literally just to make
better ads. So, spending too much time
on the learning phase is not super
smart. The main thing I want to say here
is like if you're not spending a lot of
money on ads, maybe you're spending, you
know, 50 bucks a day, a few hundred
bucks per day, even up to like a
thousand dollars per day, I think that's
kind of like the barrier. If you see
your results being like up and down,
like it literally looks like a freaking
sine wave, that is normal, okay? That's
100% normal. That's how the game works.
[__] I experience inconsistencies. I
spend way beyond 1K per day. And most
advertisers do. Facebook is an emotional
ass platform, man. It's a bunch of
emotional human beings like you and me.
Do you really expect it to be the most
consistent thing on the world? If you
want super duper consistent results,
like go advertise on Google
>> [laughter]
>> and uh you know, enjoy your time, all
right? Google's cool. It's got its own
issues, but with Facebook
inconsistencies is part of the game, but
especially at lower levels of spend,
you'll see people just bitching about,
"Oh, I was at 3X ROAS and now I'm not
profitable." I'm was "Well, how much do
you spend?" He's like, "A hundred
bucks." I'm like, "Come on. What what
are we doing here? Like, what do you
What do you expect?" So, the solution
there is to, when in doubt, zoom out.
Look at larger time frames with larger
amounts of data, and you'll see what's
really happening. Instead of being like,
"Oh, today was good really good. Next
day was really bad." I don't care. Look
at 7 days. Look at the most amount of ad
spend that you can, and that's when
you'll make the best decisions, and not
these emotional decisions where you're
just going with the [__] flow of
Facebook taking you for a ride. Nobody
wants that. All right, next I want to
talk about signal quality and your EMQ
and Conversions API. So, Facebook
performance is often times dependent on
the data that you're sending back to the
ad account and back to the Facebook
servers so that it can learn about your
customers and reduce your cost to
advertise long-term, hopefully. And with
that, that means that you have to be
sure that you're sending the best
quality data you possibly can to
Facebook because the better quality data
that you send them, often times, they're
going to be able to learn more about
your customers and send you better
customers in the future, make your ads
more efficient long-term. So, you can go
into your Events Manager and go to the
purchase event specifically, and you'll
see something called the EMQ, which is
your event match quality, and it'll be
on a scale of 1 to 10. I'm not saying
it's a direct correlation like 10 out of
10 is super profitable ads, like five
out of 10 you're going to be dog [__] I
actually think this whole concept is
overrated, but I think generally
speaking, it's a good thing to try to
send good data to Facebook. And you can
do that through Conversions API, which
is simply sending your data back
server-side and not only on the browser.
For those that have been advertising for
long enough, you know this became a big
deal around iOS 14, which was launched
in 2020, but it actually went into
effect, I think, early 2021, and
everybody's ads just kind of went to
[__] because I don't look at any
conversions after the click. Like, I
don't look at my CPA on Facebook at all.
I always use third-party attribution
tools, you know, whether that's Triple
Whale, whether that's Hyros. There's so
many of these out there. Like, you can
build one custom now. [__] you could
vibe code one probably in a few hours
and have your own solution that you
don't have to pay for at all. The issue
is, because of what the update that iOS
launched, all the users can now opt out
of tracking from Facebook. So,
everything becomes really inaccurate.
Now, if you're able to use like
conversions API, any server-side
tracking, you can improve your EMQ and
get better data into the Facebook
servers to help you optimize with your
ad account your ads a lot better than
you are right now. So, to summarize this
point, try to send Facebook good data.
And also, take all the conversion data
with a grain of salt. Okay, let's go.
Now, the third thing here is going to be
the whole concept of creative diversity.
So, because of Andromeda, there was this
really weird narrative where people are
basically saying, "Oh, there's kind of
like two types of ads that you can
test." You know, you can test something
completely new, we'll just call that
like a new concept and that new concept,
or you can test, you know, a variation.
You can only do one of the two, which
it's really not that simple, but let's
just say for these purposes, this is
what it is. And people like, "All right,
all you need to do to survive Andromeda
is just like pump out more new concepts
and do less variations." No, variations
are still highly highly effective. What
Andromeda did is let's say like this is
within an ad set and we're looking at
the ad level, and each one of these is a
new ad, right? You have ad one, two,
three, and four. So, every time I launch
creatives, I'm actually launching
variations. So, this entire ad set, per
se, will be one net new concept, but ad
number two, ad number three, and ad
number four will all be variations of
that original net new concept. So, it's
not necessarily variations of the
winner. Like it's difficult to get a
variation of like your top ad in an ad
account to outperform the top ad. It'll
do decent. It's typically not going to
outperform, at least in my experience.
But, variations are still highly
effective because you're basically
getting more at-bats at the concept
level. Technically, you're testing a new
concept, but you can test one concept
with three different hooks, and it turns
out that this variation actually ends up
being the winner, and this original like
net new concept is actually the loser.
But, if you said variations are stupid
and they don't make any sense, then you
never would have figured that out, and
you would have just concluded that this
net new concept was a loser. When in
reality, you're a loser
>> [laughter]
>> for believing that.
I swear I could rant on all this stuff
for so much longer. I'm trying to stay
focused here. Let me distill all this
technical crap into something that you
can actually take away. Because
basically what we just did is we went
through all the super autistic
scientific mathematical explanations of
how the Facebook ads algorithm actually
works, but let's take our [__] hat off
for a second and think like a Chad,
okay? Three things you should take away.
All right, number one, your creative is
the targeting. Stop trying to [__]
around so much with the ad sets
targeting, custom audiences, lookalikes.
That can be a little experimentation
sandbox, but for the most part, run
broad. The creative is the targeting.
Number two, make good creatives that
thought people from their doom scroll.
Of course, easier said than done, and
that's not even what this video is
about, but if you just have damn good
creatives, like that's literally half of
the [__] formula. It's just having
that high CTR, high soft metrics, of
course, excluding the conversions. Like
that's half the [__] battle right
there. And then third is going to be
don't [__] up the user experience. Now,
I have a portion of this video that I
intentionally left for the end of this
video for people that are genuinely
serious about figuring out how Facebook
works. And all this stuff that I've said
so far is what we'll call, you know, by
the books. A lot of it is in, you know,
Facebook's own documentation or
documentation that they had years ago
and they have since removed, but let me
tell you how the game really works.
Facebook is a for-profit [snorts]
company based in America. Facebook is a
massive, massive company. We can assume
they probably don't do everything by the
books. So, what I'm really leading to
here is Facebook doesn't play by the
rules. I could go down the list of what
this actually means, but at the end of
the day, as I said, Facebook is a
for-profit company. And like most
companies, they are trying to get the
most amount of money from the largest
advertisers, and then all the smaller
ones that cause like 99% of their
headaches, they're not going to treat
them super duper well. So, a lot of you
have probably launched ad accounts and
got them disabled, have ads rejected,
have ad accounts banned, have business
managers banned. Maybe you've had
profiles banned, but you have to
understand that Facebook is a company,
and they're a company that is public.
And what happens when you run a public
company is you have to answer to your
shareholders, which means depending on
how the earnings reports come out
regarding Facebook, Facebook is either
going to constrict their guidelines,
their restrictions, and this is where
you see ban waves come through, which is
where everybody's just getting their ad
account banned, everybody's dealing with
business manager bans, page bans, and
then a month later it's like totally
fine. That's all due mostly to earnings
reports that are coming out directly
from Facebook. So, depending on how
those look, they will either be way more
laid back, way more chill, or super
duper strict. That's why saying, "Oh,
you can't run like this type of format
of ad on Facebook." One person runs it,
gets approved. Another person runs an
identical creative and gets it rejected.
Why is that? Well, Facebook don't play
about their rules, all right? So, what
do you do about this? I mean, I'm not
going to get too much into specifics
because I don't know if I can. I think
the main thing anyone can take away from
this is just question everything. Like,
when I was talking about the CAPI and
the signal quality and the EMQ score,
technically speaking, like it makes
sense logically, theoretically, if
you're able to get higher quality data
back to Facebook, they should be able to
optimize better. However, I haven't seen
a direct correlation between that. I
have had really, really good server-side
setups to where my EMQ was like 9.8,
9.9. The little thing on my freaking ad
account was like, matter of fact, I'll
show you. I'm literally at a zero
>> [laughter]
>> at a zero opportunity score, and this ad
account is incredibly profitable. So,
all the [__] from Facebook, they're
still wanting to get money from you. So,
just because they say something or it's
in their documentation or like their
CEO, CMO, head of advertising is like,
"This is what advertisers should do."
[__] it. Think for yourself, question
everything. And I want to take a moment
of silence for everyone that listened to
all the Facebook suggestions at the ad
level that said they would lower your
cost per result by 11% and then their
ads went to [__] RIP. Don't listen to
Facebook. Other than that, guys, I hope
you enjoyed. Thank you so much for
watching this video. See you on the next
one. Peace.